because to my new wife the Empress of
Russia it is now you don't talk my love
oh of course
must be an enormous responsibility and
honor to lead a country of such input
it's actually not that hard I'm happy to
hear anyone's problems with me don't
worry about the bodies I would like to
be useful to Russia to help its
greatness kill them is there is no
higher use rabbit these sticks are to
enhance your fertility cannot work out
whether we wave them over your room or
insert them into you we're pretty sure
it's a wave limb situation together we
could create a crater Russia well I will
you sir your bride is unhappy you must
clear the clouds we should find you a
lot
[Music]
Marvis I'd like to be alone
now you should create the day together
with sunny dispositions fearless Hut's
we shall discuss whether or not to kill
the Empress she is a strange creature
who I sense is at times laughing at me
Empress there are unhappy been here
looking for a leader
if the Emperor dies Russia goes to the
Empress
[Music]
Russia must be saved and I with it I
don't want to kill you you're not a bad
person I could kill you you are a bad
person you're funny
treason is what we're discussing here
[Music]
it's a dangerous game out worry
all is bliss in the court of Catherine
the Great
[Music]
- sure do you mean Touche
this is science enjoy
[Music]
you
you